I and welcome back to Sarah's music
today we're in New York it's rather cold
but very sunny and we're really happy to
be here and now we're going to find the
Carnegie Hall excuse me where's the
Carnegie Hall oh okay thank you excuse
me you're from New York yes I am how do
we get to Carnegie Hall practice
practice practice okay doesn't work keep
walking up to just thank you off we go
wake up in a city that doesn't sleep
we're on the corner of seventh avenue of
57th Street and here is the Carnegie
Hall one of my favorite concert halls in
the whole world the acoustic is really
incredible and when I'm on stage playing
a concert I'm always incredibly happy
and proud to be there and I think this
feeling is shared by every musician who
plays on that stage Carnegie Hall was
built in 1890 by Andrew Carnegie in
American steel tycoon this landmark
building houses three concert halls the
largest of which the stern auditorium
perelman stage seats two thousand eight
hundred people on five levels we're
going in but not through the main door
we're going into the stage door
keep your rolling guy's this guy's the
most important man today we're very
alive over so we're backstage at the
carnegie hall and i'm just about to go
on to the stage this is where the
musicians wait before the concert and
it's an amazing feeling to walk out onto
this stage come and have a look you
thank you hi isn't this absolutely
amazing
Oh
sir clive killington the executive and
artistic director of the carnegie hall
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak to me today I love being here even
if I'm not playing my horn what makes
Carnegie Hall such a special place well
I mean it's fascinating how it was a
mistake of history almost because you
probably know Andrew Carnegie's wife
saying in a chorus in it there was no
concert or she also husband to go to the
concert hall as you do and he said yes I
would like to find a husband who would
build me a song and then they didn't go
to the greatest architect they went to
someone who'd never build a concert or
who is the treasurer of her floral
society sent him around Europe to look
at all the great concert of as he
designed something the bore no
relationship to anything he'd seen and
he built the greatest concert hall in
the world and about the acoustic of the
Carnegie Hall is it naturally fantastic
or did anything have to be tweaked well
the astonishing thing is he got it right
straight first game oh it's magic I mean
it's one of the well the thing one knows
is I mean for all the fact that
everybody says it's about science it's a
science and it's an art as well and
because otherwise every single new
concert hall that went up would be a
great concert or which business so the
fact is he must have just known and
understand music because when you look
at it talk to our decisions today
they'll say great concert of all should
be should shoe box shape shouldn't have
curves as well as curves front and back
they should be about 2,000 seats this is
2800 so we did everything wrong he did
it better than anybody's ever done it
before or since and he never built
another concert hall but it also means
we have to look after it in a crazy way
I mean
you know because the seats were
originally made in Canada by a company
120 whatever it is years ago we still
send them back up there to exactly the
same maker do it because even the fabric
effects acoustic back in there and it
every single thing and whatever's inside
the seat as well so every single thing
affects the acoustics yeah you know so
the plaster does so if you do any work
on the plaster walls you've got to be
really careful and make sure that you'll
be it's the same density so you look
after your acoustic so that we can come
and play here and be totally happy on
today
I'm on stage with lake over and he's
just finished the first office of his
rehearsal and I'm dying to find out why
why you think this acoustic is one of
the best in the world it has a certain
beauty it's very very difficult to
define it I find especially in the soft
nuances there is some glow to the sound
here and what is really magical about
that is that amazing 2,800 see it all
and when I play recycle here I feel I
can play as soft as I want and I feel
the Sun comes back from you know the
last seeds of the road it's maybe that's
an illusion but so does the sound tells
me that it carries you post it on your
Instagram feed something that touched me
very much you said after the first notes
you had the feeling that this whole set
whispered welcome back and I know
exactly what you mean because when I
come on here on the stage to play for
the first time we just see and you think
wow it's just even welcome home hey
welcome home you know it's like this
homecoming if there's something so
comfortable and homely about the sounds
the difference between you today you
have to back to the audience all the
time because you're the conductor today
as well cuz usually in recital you you
at least have the side view it's in a
different way of performing do you feel
a little bit more detached or do you
feel more involved in the music oh then
if I'm playing oh yeah then you're
playing I feel more involved because I'm
so in the middle of the music you know
I'm saying I have such a I contact and
and I hear extremely well the orchestra
and they hear me very well so there are
real advantages to this way of upsetting
and performing obviously then there are
some disadvantages I don't have a lid on
the piano
it doesn't protect the class do you have
to play differently I have to play very
clearly this hole is like a cushion
metzli it's it can be then a little bit
blurry in certain passages so I have to
make sure to pay very distinctly and
clearly
you know but generally we just you know
we just play our hearts out so it's
inspiring here and it is like it's kind
of you don't want to give yes just want
to give ya the whole is channels and we
become generously photo collection is
incredible of all the people who
performed here at carnegie hall and look
the ultimate New Yorker Leonard
Bernstein
so with a hundred and seventy concerts
which Carnegie presents every year
that's a lot of artistic planning and
jeremy Geffen is the director of
artistic fanny Jerry that's a lot of
work really it takes a village we all
pull this how many are you there are six
of us only artistic planning to and
that's a lot of artists to look after
because not only do you plan you have to
look after them when they come here yeah
I mean they don't lived in its New York
City everybody's tends to know somebody
here so they don't need so much looking
after but occasionally we do have
situations so you have a lot of a lot of
personal contacts to the to the to your
your stars and um you you have to meet
them you meet them in their most
intimate moments like 10 minutes before
a performance you know performers are
used to being on the road and they'd go
from one venue to another so there most
of them are accustomed to this lifestyle
this vagabond lifestyle there are
moments that that come up because
they're vagabonds that well that you
have to do some creative problem solving
no names tell me I do remember once
knocking on a conductors dressing room
door just before our performance and
being told to come in and he was there
in in just his underwear and he said
there were a couple of other people in
the room he said the orchestra forgot to
bring my of my tales there was someone
in charge of ring everything his fix his
concert clothes wit and he he said we
think we've got a jacket and a pair of
trousers for from the orchestra but and
we can't find a shirt and I live a block
in Carnegie Hall and asked what his size
was he told me and I was close to mines
that I ran it was it was a particularly
cold night it was below zero Celsius and
ran home picked up the shirt ran back
and actually by the time I got back
someone had already given him one
anything goes at Carnegie not every day
we just like to think that if we we have
standards so that's all from Sarah's
music from today I
you've enjoyed being at Carnegie Hall
I've loved being here again and now I'm
going to practice practice practice see
you next time
so late overs just asked me if he can
play the piano instead but no way this
is the horn challenge you live together
with a horn player so you should know
how to do this here we go I have never
tried and here this is for you not bad
and that was almost a Valkyrie yeah
that's my ghost inaudible thank you okay
go back to your piano thank you